Terminator: Dark Fate has screened for critics
— and while the franchise has left them
cold in recent years, it looks like the trend
is about to be reversed.
"I'm back."
A good deal of the reviewers who took in the
film are comparing it favorably to Terminator
2: Judgment Day, and many also agreed that
the film will make a star out of Mackenzie
Davis.
Linda Hamilton's return to the role of Sarah
Connor was welcomed, and the flick's intriguing
story and slam-bang action sequences were
also singled out for praise.
Having said that, we're cautiously optimistic
that the initial reactions to Terminator:
Dark Fate will hold up, because the flick
comes with a pretty darn sterling pedigree.
It functions as a direct sequel to T2, ignoring
all of the increasingly ridiculous sequels
that followed that film.
"Talk to the hand"
It also marks James Cameron's return to the
franchise as a producer, and it was helmed
by Tim Miller, the man who brought us the
piece of pure cinematic joy that was 2016's
Deadpool.
Gabriel Luna has been well known among Marvel
circles since his inspired performance as
Ghost Rider in Marvel's Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.,
and fans are no doubt excited that he plays
a souped-up Terminator in this movie.
So what do the critics have to say about it?
For starters, the folks at Collider were roundly
blown away by the flick.
Editor-in-chief Steven Weintraub was among
the many praising the performance of Davis,
who stars as a cyborg sent back in time to
protect a new "mother of the future" portrayed
by Natalia Reyes.
Weintraub enjoyed the trifecta offered by
Davis, Reyes, and Hamilton.
He wrote
"[Terminator: Dark Fate] is easily the best
Terminator movie since T2.
Has some fantastic action and loved how the
film features 3 female protagonists that all
kick ass.
So awesome seeing Linda Hamilton back as Sarah
Connor."
In a followup tweet, Weintraub had a word
of recommendation for those unfamiliar with
Davis' work, writing:
"I've been a fan of Mackenzie Davis since
seeing her in Halt and Catch Fire.
But she takes it to another level in [Dark
Fate] where she kicks all kinds of ass.
If you like her work in Dark Fate, go back
and watch [Halt and Catch Fire]."
Collider editor Perri Nemiroff seemed a touch
surprised to be penning such a positive response,
saying:
"Is [Terminator: Dark Fate] the best since
T2?
Yup.
Linda Hamilton's return makes a BIG difference,
Mackenzie Davis kicks all the ass, & Natalia
Reyes is an excellent anchor.
Gabriel Luna's Rev-9 is a winner too.
Physicality, VFX, fights — all spot on!
Glad they gave this another go."
Their colleague, horror editor Haleigh Foutch,
offered a similar opinion:
"It's solid.
Super well articulated action.
Linda Hamilton is aces.
Easily the best sequel since T2.
[Dark Fate] takes The Force Awakens' 'if it
ain't broke, don't fix it' mentality to Cameron's
films and turns out it ain't broke."
Ms. Foutch was not the only observer to notice
an aesthetic similarity between Dark Fate
and the movie that washed the bad taste of
the Star Wars prequels out of the mouths of
fans.
Gizmodo entertainment reporter Germain Lussier
wrote:
"[The movie is] basically Terminator: The
Force Awakens.
A satisfying, exciting reboot that's essentially
the best parts of T1 & T2 in a blender.
Davis, Reyes & Hamilton are excellent, the
action wows & while it's familiar, it's easily
the best T3 yet.
Terminator is back."
Slashfilm owner-editor Peter Sciretta also
drew the comparison, although he did make
sure to point out that Miller is, well, no
Cameron.
"[Dark Fate] is better than you think it's
going to be.
It's trying hard to be the Force Awakens of
Terminator movies, and mostly succeeds.
But it's lacking Cameron's innovation, evolution
and directing.
Arnold is fantastic, the best of his post
T2 Terminator appearances."
Sciretta wasn't the only to sing the praises
of Arnie, who has certainly caught his share
of flak for continuing to show up in the Terminator
franchise well into his golden years.
Of course, there was also plenty of praise
to go around for Hamilton, who apparently
had no trouble slipping back into the skin
of her most famous character.
Uproxx senior entertainment writer Mike Ryan
said:
"I was skeptical of [Dark Fate].
Thought the trailers were not great.
But I would up enjoying it quite a bit, and
the difference maker (vs the other post T2
sequels) is Linda Hamilton.
It's always been HER story and Hamilton adds
the needed weight here."
Screencrush editor-in-chief Matt Singer agreed
wholeheartedly.
"[Terminator is] thought of as Arnold's franchise.
[Dark Fate] makes it clear he wasn't the key
ingredient that made it work.
It was Linda Hamilton.
She's incredible in this, and the movie's
very solid."
All in all, it was a pretty amazing outpouring
of love for a sequel that nobody was sure
would work, and it seems to have accomplished
the impossible in making some critics actually
look forward to more Terminator movies.
These initial reactions certainly seem to
confirm that Terminator: Dark Fate may finally,
at long last, be a Terminator movie that doesn't
come out of the gate having to justify its
existence.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.